reencuentro
[Música]
es la traducción del francés pero
escuchado toma darío en español
no me suena muy bien no conozco el
dromedario cuando estamos entonces
decíamos con este reencuentro semanal
como dice pablo que es renovamos desde
este espacio en nuestro servicio español
de radio canadá internacional es viernes
una vez más tenemos que todos ustedes
esperan y viernes el cuerpo lo sabe
la gente pero el viernes pero no porque
se trate del fin de la semana a elaborar
el principio del descanso de la
diversión sino porque espera en este
momento para ver estas bellezas que
estamos aquí en este estudio está dando
este despliegue de simpatía de humor y
de amor mejor vídeo por también les
ofrecemos desde aquí el equipo en
español del rollo que nada hoy estamos
presentes
una versión cuasi reducida en el estudio
estamos tanto por eso así en el estudio
estamos pablo gómez barrios más muy bien
lo es muchas gracias y saludos a todo el
mundo allá muy bien paloma martínez
vos también también hasta el momento
todo va bien decía el pavo mientras lo
iban metiendo al horno mi nombre es luis
laborda y nuestro compañero habitual
leonardo el elemento clave del que
hacemos mención en el cual sí claro
no es que esté ausente en el día de hoy
sino que está del otro lado del vidrio
haciéndose cargo de parte de los
controles de todo ese despliegue
tecnológico que tenemos técnico además
posición para poner en aire esta emisión
y nos saluda también con benoit y con
marcándole que están del otro lado
también de las cabinas que nosotros
ese es el equipo completo
está faltando pierde útil para que sea
completo
[Música]
pero la semana próxima al parecer solas
para va a estar presente una vez más con
nosotros compartiendo también esta
alegría
de lo que se pierde abrirlos que también
los que no están trabajando si densa
ventas respectivamente
bueno muy bien
vamos a poner en marcha esta emisión
después de estos chascarrillos que
siempre damos al principio como para
romper un poco el hielo como se dice
informan que el hielo nos falta
efectivamente y a eso vamos porque uno
de los temas que nos ha concitado la
atención a lo largo de esta semana pero
sobre todo en las últimas horas es la
extensa y grave fuerte tormenta invernal
que se abate sobre buena parte del
territorio canadiense principalmente en
este momento lo que es el este del país
aunque también ha afectado llavero este
es ánimo de columbia británica alberta
que es una provincia que no está
acostumbrada a temperaturas tan bajas
como las que están viviendo en este
momento y está habituado a la nieve pero
un caudal mucho menor del que ha caído
en las últimas horas pero por éste
esta misma mañana nosotros veíamos
imágenes paloma se debe acordar porque
la gesta de comentamos en algún momento
y los efectos que la tormenta está
teniendo en el este del país y la verdad
que son imágenes impacta por un lado
cómicas
y en otros casos son impactantes digamos
un señor un cronista un colega en
realidad del canal en inglés de la bici
que estaba haciendo un reporte desde la
calle ensayo de terranova
más arriba de las rodillas tenían mucha
dificultad de caminar era gracioso verlo
pero en realidad estaba mostrando
imagínese yo no puedo caminar aquí en la
calle salir de casa desplazarse a algún
lugar es difícil si lo hubiera sugerido
de ponerse raquetas si hubiera tenido un
colchón de nieve muy alto tengo yo aquí
algunos datos no es lo que ha
precipitado hasta el momento pero se
espera que hasta el fin de la jornada
toda esa zona del país y principalmente
la zona de sabillón y algunas
municipalidades cercanas reciban 75
centímetros
así que ya ni con patinetas las cosas
están flotadores rotador especialmente
hemos puesto en nuestro sitio alguna
imagen que tal vez leonardo pueda
mostrarnos de algunas fotos de lo que ha
ocurrido en las últimas horas ahí en el
este del país
la tormenta se llama en inglés blizzard
nieve viento etcétera etcétera que hace
que como en esa imagen que ustedes están
observando ahí la visibilidad sea
bastante dificultosa cuando estás bien
peligroso y hay que manejar con mucho
cuidado hasta caminar y hasta caminar es
el desplazamiento en cualquier de
cualquier tipo que sea exactamente
porque de hecho a veces uno uno va
manejando o caminando y tanto el peatón
como el conductor tienen dificultad a
verse entre sí entonces hay que tener
muchísimas muchísimas imágenes de una
bicicleta y de hecho yo estaba pensando
precisamente ahí hay un vídeo que nos
muestra imágenes lo que ha ocurrido
también en las últimas horas tiene un
audio pero hay un relato en inglés por
lo que lo hemos dejado bajo o eliminado
nosotros seguimos comentando lo que ha
ocurrido y en relación a lo que decíamos
recién yo pienso en eso continuamente
porque veo que las advertencias van
siempre ligadas a los automovilistas a
los conductores mejor dicho
casualmente el otro día viendo yo en el
autobús hacia aquí una señora cruzó la
avenida sin mar en la ribera sur por
donde venía circulando el autobús y paso
por delante del mismo cuando éste venía
rodando venía circulando por esa avenida
y el chofer por supuesto le dijo en
algún momento señora no es una muy buena
idea cruzar de noche a la hora que yo
vengo para aquí todavía está oscuro no
es una muy buena idea que usar de noche
y ante la llegada del autobús apurándose
para tomarlo porque porque el chofer
tuvo unos reflejos y freno pero el
automóvil en este caso el autobús puede
seguir y puede no quedar en el lugar
donde el chofer quiso frenarlo y golpear
en este caso a esta señora
oa uno oa otro automóvil he visto
accidentes de autos aunque el chofer ha
frenado el auto se sigue desplazando y
golpea la automóvil que está delante
entonces hay que tener mucho cuidado hay
que ir a una distancia prudente hay que
una velocidad también prudente
por supuesto estar bien equipada
cubierta el invierno hay que estar bien
despierto hay que olvidarse de poner la
calefacción a todo lo que da porque a
veces crea también una cierta especie de
vaho que no permite moverse o no permite
reaccionar con la velocidad necesaria
pues ustedes tienen algunas imágenes lo
que ha venido ocurriendo ahora es en el
este de canadá en la región atlántica de
canadá pero digamos que esta mañana aquí
en montreal estaba haciendo bastante
frío mira está enseñar caminando en la
nieve que está demostrando como la nieve
casi lo tapar y así no se ve ese
caminito hecho
bueno pero aquí de mañana nos
despertamos y hacía frío bastante frío
bastante frío andaban diciendo menos 30
grados bajo cero por lo que escucha con
el viento es el adiós adiós famosa
sensación de la sensación térmica pero
la temperatura real creo que era 20 o 21
grados bajo cero
bastante fresco también de todas maneras
misiones como decía un amigo base más
más abajo de los 15 todo igual te da
igual es verdad no hace mucha diferencia
ahora algo que tenemos que tener
mencionar es que pablo por ejemplo con
este frío y todo vino en bicicleta y
estábamos hablando la semana pasada de
las bicicletas en el invierno y pablo
sigue firme en su decisión y aunque
hacía mucho frío y había mucha y el
problema es que ahora me tengo que
regresar en bicicleta pero si tuviéramos
los recursos para hacerlo ahí podría
lanzar una encuesta entonces podría
haber sido tranquilamente pablo gómez
barrios valiente o inconsciente
pero bueno también es cierto que a pesar
del frío que hoy llegó en gran
intensidad aunque hasta el momento
realmente el invierno se ha portado
relativamente bien por esta zona del
país junto con el frío también llegó
otra cosa algo que no teníamos hace
muchos días
sí señor y bueno inquieto porque no ves
la luz del sol estoy preguntando desde
que llegué a sellaba algunos cuantos
días dónde está eso que brilla a veces
en el cielo y en algunos cielos está
medio bronceado
louis por no decir pronunciado del todo
sí bueno era que estaba pues allá
haciendo haciendo una colecta de sol en
la habana y la van a parar en baradero
sino en el caribe dando algunas vueltas
tenemos que verificar algunas
situaciones y el otro dice una una
prueba me saque una foto una de esas
autofotos que se llaman selfish que yo
realmente las aborrezco pero hice la
prueba para mandarse algunos amigos me
coloque delante de una puerta marrón que
tengo en mi casa y yo estaba más oscuro
que la puerta
así que él solo ha sido suficiente con
nosotros que no hemos tenido el invierno
así es duro sobre todo hoy en la mañana
aunque estaba en la ventana de por medio
me puse y tomé un poco de sol que
entraba por la ventana a un lado de la
oficina porque algo algo de vitaminas
vitaminas de chip debe pasar por la
ventana no debe saber aquí se venden
como muchos países en muchos lugares
donde hay climas similares a este unos
aparatitos que reproducen la luz solar
para la gente para que la gente se los
pueda utilizar y
a suministrarse a sí misma un poco de
esos rayos necesarios como para que el
organismo siga funcionario para
aprovecharse para mantenerse en salud y
en muchos casos se utiliza también en
estadios leves de depresión porque
sabemos que la falta de sol muy
prolongada puede provocar entre otras
cosas una depresión leve no de las más
severas ni mucho menos y se usa en se
usa esa lámpara para contrarrestar
alguno de los efectos de la carencia de
sol de la falta del sol
sabemos en rúsia yo me enteré de que
estas lámparas usaban incluso durante la
guerra cuando los soldados tenían que
permanecer durante mucho tiempo
escondidos ante la posibilidad de
ataques del enemigo además del invierno
crudo que hay en algunas regiones de
rusia está el escondido y esconderse de
la luz del día para que el enemigo no lo
pudiese ver hacía que estuvieran más que
pálidos
usaban alguna de esas lámparas para
levantar un poco no el color sino el
ánimo
si yo a veces he mostrado fotos de
cuando vivía yo en méxico y mi color de
piel era muy diferente era mucho más
oscuro porque estaba uno expuesto al sol
más constantemente entonces bueno la
depresión no me ha llegado pero a veces
estoy más cansado y hay que decir que
hay que reconocer educación pero lo
hablamos con buscar lucas jr paloma es
de edad del invierno aquí hay mucho sol
en general si el sol es bastante intenso
incluso en el invierno es sólo un
poquito eres tú el que dice
[Música]
pero no siempre dices ah pero yo si me
pongo así en la calle incluso a recibir
los rayitos de sol se calienta si yo
tengo pruebas de hecho hay mensajitos
aquí que nos han llegado de gente que
nos está viendo por facebook live hay 11
personas conectadas así que gracias por
estar
siguiéndonos por por facebook la presión
11 veces exacto que lo compartan con sus
amigos y todos los para que nos sigan
viendo ismael zamora dice saludos desde
salvatierra méxico también gustavo lucas
saludos desde ciudad me lo en uruguay en
cerro largo uruguay y dice aquí con
calor pero yo vi un poco y está más
fresco muy bien aquí todos los demás que
nos estén viendo pues que no saluden que
nos manden algún comentario sobre el
frío sobre el calor sobre como lo están
pasando por allá y yo quiero antes de
que le demos la palabra un mensaje
especial a mi mamá
también por qué porque no se ve muy bien
pero esta blusa que traigo es una cosa
que me envió mi mamá yo regreso de
méxico de vacaciones de navidad y es una
blusa que está hecha que le llaman
deshilado y eso es un tipo de técnica de
digamos artesanal de la región donde yo
crecí en aguascalientes en méxico que
está en el centro de la república
entonces ahí la podemos ver
entonces gracias mami por esta blusa que
me encantó
puedes cordial saludo para patricia ya
en otro lado si nos está viendo no saber
qué sé que se manifieste aquí
el clima de lado que es un tema que todo
el día es un tema recurrente pero bueno
la realidad nos obliga nos obliga en ese
sentido hay otro tema que también nos ha
concitado la atención
varios días que tiene que ver con la
presunta o casi segura llegada a canadá
de parte de la familia o de miembros
hasta ahora miembros formales de la
familia real británica hablamos del
príncipe harry de su esposa megan que en
poco tiempo más estarían afincados al
menos parte del año en territorio
canadiense a ello se anunció nanas en
pocos días de que desean abandonar las
las obligaciones oficiales que en él sin
varones alojarse retraerse de los
flashes de las cámaras de fotos de la
atención pública abandonar esas
funciones oficiales por suerte aclararon
también que abandonarían los beneficios
financieros que van que conllevan esas
actividades este oficiales y pertenecer
o de tentar el rango que detentan
príncipe duquesa etcétera
y en fin hasta el momento yo no entiendo
muy bien por qué deberían pasar una
época en canadá sabes que pasaron ya no
pasaron seis semanas en canadá durante
el mes de noviembre de diciembre y hasta
una parte de enero estuvieron seis
semanas en canadá en la región de la
isla d
en victoria hacer cadena en la región de
vancouver bueno en columbia británica
más bien en la provincia de columbia
británica en el oeste canadiense donde
hace menos frío
llueve mucho sale poco el sol soraya
pero pasaron seis semanas allá
estuvieron en el bosque se ven fotos de
ellos por allí paseando por el bosque
nada malo con eso nada malo con eso y
parece que además megan tiene una
relación especial con canadá porque
vivió en toronto por ocho años por lo
menos estudió aquí también creo que
estudió pero lo que sí sé es que estuvo
filmando una serie de televisión que fue
muy muy conocida y que sigue haciéndolo
en realidad schütz que se llama yo nos
abogados etcétera en la ciudad de
toronto supuestamente no sucedió en
toronto pero
todo fue filmado ahí entonces ya conoce
toronto conoce la vida en canadá le
gustan más tiene un montón de amigos acá
así que de hecho amiga del hijo y la
familia digamos del hijo del ex primer
ministro canadiense brian mulroney es
amiga del hijo y de la esposa del hijo
de brian mulroney y de hecho los hijos
de esta pareja fueron de los pajes en la
son dos pequeñitos que fueron pajes
durante la boda exactamente entonces hay
varias relaciones de la pareja con
canadá ahora es que los canadienses
quieren que se vengan para el sur
porque el tema ha despertado pasión
interés y la pasión puede ser tanto a
favor como en contra y hay gente que
está a favor de que vengan aquí porque
dicen que como parte de la de la corona
en todo caso canadá se vería honrada con
la presencia del mismo de jarrio de la
duquesa
megan pero hay otra parte de gente que
está muy preocupada
yo me inscribo entre ellos en todo caso
por el hecho de que la presencia de
estas de estos dos personajes aquí
obligue obligaría entre otras cosas a un
despliegue por ejemplo de seguridad
etcétera que por supuesto conlleva
gastos y esos gastos señoras y señores
de dónde salen buenos impuestos que
pagamos todos los que yo me estuve
leyendo al respecto es que no
necesariamente porque canadá como
recordaremos es parte de la mancomunidad
de naciones del reino unido sin embargo
tiene una particularidad con el que la
distingue digamos de nueva zelanda y de
australia es que los otros países de la
mancomunidad porque canadá restituyó rap
repatrió la constitución y al repatriar
la constitución eso la de slim lo
deslinda canadá de sus obligaciones con
la corona directamente en este caso la
seguridad de los de los duques de sussex
tendría que estar directamente
relacionada con la corona en reino unido
no en canadá canadá no desplegaría
dinero al respecto por el propio primer
ministro sustituto elevó el tema y dijo
que era una de las preocupaciones del
gobierno sí claro y el ministro de
finanzas también lo dijo no hemos
discutido pero no estamos seguros de que
lo haremos que hay que hay quien para
beneficio de los que nos están
escuchando y viendo allá del otro lado
de los micrófonos y de las cámaras que
canadá es una monarquía constitucional
entonces en la que el primer ministro
pues ellos centro do pero la jefa del
estado finalmente
la reina de inglaterra entonces en tanto
que miembros de la mancomunidad
británica de naciones
de monarquía constitucional debe asumir
algunos gastos o sea cuando la la reina
o sea cualquier miembro de la realeza
británica viaja a canadá en general
canadá asume todos los gastos que
implica ese desplazar pero como ellos
vienen en transición a su independencia
financiera porque eso lo que anunciaron
en realidad no solamente la que se
distanciaban de sus obligaciones reales
bueno bueno sería que se quieren
distanciar de sus obligaciones pero no
del financiamiento no entonces por eso
pero si quieren ser independientes
financieramente ojalá que lo logre me
imagino no es también la calle no ya se
harry debe tener un montón de plata de
hecho creo que recibió dinero de su
madre directamente lo cual está
deslindado completamente del dinero que
vendía de la corona su madre le heredó
mucho más dinero a él que a william
porque william va a ser rey un día
el tema pasa un poco como decía pablo de
que esta gente tiene
si el gran dios ciertos privilegios su
desplazamiento su presencia de hecho
obliga a ciertas disposiciones que de
todas maneras creo que ningún país puede
evadir yo recuerdo visitas de jefes de
estado
recuerdo la visita de la madre esta
gente le diría a la argentina argentina
no tiene ningún tipo de relación a nivel
corona británica- con esta familia
y sin embargo cuando la princesa daiana
visitó este buenos aires nos recordará
si fue algún otro lugar pero si estuvo
en buenos aires- de hecho yo me crucé
con su pequeña caravana en algún momento
había dispositivo de seguridad y el
gobierno argentino está obligado a
destinar a sus desplazamientos o sea
gastos hay de todas maneras y como
veíamos en una de las fotos que mostraba
que hemos leonardo recién habíamos el
castillo de windsor por ejemplo esta
gente está acostumbrada a ese tipo de
instalaciones y no va a venir a ubicarse
un departamento de dos ambientes digamos
ese tipo de posibilidad que se me sus
semis un suelo de esos que abundan por
aquí no es el suelo que está disponible
ahí y se acomoda a él y vemos qué
hacemos después bueno la cuestión es que
era la discusión está abierta hay gente
que está a favor hay gente que está en
contra hay gente que quiere que venga la
gente que no quiere que vengan yo
supongo que van a venir de todas maneras
lo interesante sería que se aclare una
vez por todas qué va a pasar quién se va
a encargar de esos gastos y también qué
es lo que vas a hacer acá porque no creo
que vengan únicamente a esta pero los
viste no la semana esta semana estuvo
mega porque megan ya está en canadá hay
que recordar harry se quedó para
discutir con su familia negociar cómo
iba a ser la cosa pero megan después de
las seis semanas fue a londres un par de
días y luego se volvió porque el niño
archi su hijo se quedó acá con la con la
nana entonces ella volvió a canadá está
en canadá y ya tuvo algunas actividades
digamos públicas
que no sé si fue la corona inglesa que
se las adjudicó o si ella fue
directamente pero fue a una casa de
ayuda para mujeres violentadas y mujeres
en dificultad en la región de vancouver
entonces fue y estaba en jeans estaba
todo muy despeinada
y estaba conversando con las mujeres
allá de todos orígenes y bueno tal vez
su presencia casera de ese tipo no
sabemos pero lo que sí sabemos es que
gran mayor y la gran mayoría de los
canadienses yo tengo no quieres pagar
porque me gana y revivan acá no pueden
pagarse los hermanos impuestos que no
paga suficientemente alto como para
encima sumar otro gasto más de estas
características por es indígena no es un
aporte extra que se hace para solventar
la subsistencia de una familia que está
en necesidad que tiene un accidente
hablamos con pablo segundo santos dentro
del programa
canadá acaba de anunciar el pago de una
compensación no indemnización una
compensación a los mil 25 mil dólares a
los familiares de las víctimas del avión
siniestrado bueno no sin grado menor y
venirán por dos misiles bueno ese tipo
de gastos son más entendibles son más
aceptables son en todo caso creo yo
menos discutibles más humanitarios más
solidarios este tipo de gastos no sus
culturas además esta semana te
presentaste un informe sobre si el
informe sobre la pobreza entre los niños
canadienses entonces cuando cuando pones
en en la balanza la importancia de
erradicar la pobreza en un país como
canadá pues comparada con los gastos que
pueden generar estos personajes pues
evidentemente la balanza se va hacia los
niños pobres en canadá entonces entonces
sí
pero si nos damos cuerda seguro bueno
vamos a darle entonces espacio primero a
la aplicación móvil de radio canadá
internacional habitualmente leonardo
gimeno es el que nos presenta este
recurso en este caso va a ser paloma y
va a comentar
es verdad sucintamente sucintamente
bueno ya saben la esta aplicación es
ésta nuestro sitio de internet la pueden
encontrar pueden encontrar en realidad
los enlaces directos a las dos
principales tiendas de aplicaciones que
es la google store play store google
store play store y la appstore entonces
ahí pueden comprarla para android o para
el sistema operativo apple y la pueden
bajar en el idioma que les plazca
nosotros recomendamos que los
disponibles les recomendamos por
supuesto que la bajen en español porque
ya aparecen todos nuestros contenidos
informativos en los diversos formatos
y a partir de nuestra aplicación en
español pueden ver también los
contenidos en francés y en inglés
directamente ya partir de esos trabajos
en los otros idiomas
en español con contenidos sustanciosos
centrales temas que son de pura
actualidad y que además nos comenten lo
que les parece esta aplicación qué tal
que no les gusta
falta que le quitarían que le agregarían
emisión no hemos incluido nosotros y el
público cree que sería interesante tener
allí
un comentario sobre los duques de sussex
feli feli león que es un súper fan nos
dice bienvenidos los duques imaginamos
pero que paguen sus cosas
si no [ __ ] desarrollo los puertos no
lo que hagamos de cerrarles la cuenta
bancaria y bueno aquí hay otro mensaje
de javier gonzález nungaray que dice
saludos cordiales para todos desde la
perla tapatía guadalajara méjico segundo
programa del año 2020 y de verdad
nuestro segundo programa del año ya no
queremos ir de nuevo
nelson contreras rincón dice buenas
tardes amigos de ersa y saludos desde
barranquilla colombia gracias
ya debe estar prendido barranquilla para
los carnavales si por otro lado es ra
medina nos está mirando liliana paredes
también nos está mirando leónidas los
tantos nacimientos que hace tiempo que
no nos saludaba dice saludos desde
brasil a mis amigos de erse y estoy
buscando a él dice gustavo lucas comenta
dice el programa en español es de los
más seguidos en rs y he visto las
transmisiones en chino y en francés
porque el siguiente o los idiomas y
había una sola
zonas conectadas sería solo yo dice
[Risas]
dice que pablo nombraba a los carnavales
ahí podemos invitarlo a nuestro para que
haga una pequeña crónica de los
carnavales por favor los viernes
carnavaleros allá de una verbena y
comerte el ambiente en barranquilla
así pues nosotros podemos mostrarles a
todos los que nos están escuchando y
viendo cómo es la cosa en barranquilla
en carnaval
como decías vive un vídeo unas imágenes
algún comentario hablado o todo eso
junto ya te estamos poniendo a trabajar
y cuando estamos entonces cumpliendo la
primera media hora de misión
[Risas]
vamos a ir a unas fotos sobre lo que va
a hacer en poco tiempo más la nueva sede
de radio canadá y dónde vamos a estar
nosotros también hay algunas fotos que
sacó nuestro compañero pablo me preguntó
grafo oficial
la entrada de la nueva sede me pareció
curioso porque había una valla hubo una
valla desde hace mucho tiempo y ya la
quitaron y esto es lo que se puede verme
ahora cuando pasamos por la esquina de
la calle
re nl beck y para pino que es donde está
situado este nuevo edificio de cristal
que yo me decía qué bueno que van a
tener que tener un presupuesto para
lavar los vidrios porque en la esquina
en la que está que se hace mucho atrás
acá en donde hay mucho tráfico pues van
a necesitarlo y ese es el interior es el
interior que te vas descubriendo contigo
porque yo no lo he visto es un material
producido por la propia casa
nos envió hace unos días atrás ahí se
puede ver además de las fotos que vos
hiciste desde el exterior tendremos
algunas de las instalaciones es un
esplai con una velocidad que ellos
mismos han puesto lamentablemente un
poco acelerada
[Risas]
pero ven como sea por adentro va
quedando también completada la cosa
falta por supuesto nosotros
lo más importante que es el recurso
humano que somos nosotros los que vamos
a darle vida a parís y más o menos del
otoño se dijo que a partir del otoño en
su en principio ha habido una extensión
de los plazos porque en principio la
mudanza debía comenzar en los primeros
meses del año en febrero y en febrero
pero bueno ha habido alguna demora con
algunas cosas no es fácil tampoco mudar
un complejo radiofónico y televisivo
como es este que difunde las 24 horas
sobre 24 horas entonces lo que estaban
diciendo es que tienen que hacer equipos
paralelos entonces en el momento en el
que ésta entras
cuando digamos transfiriendo los muebles
los equipos y todo y tiene que haber
otros equipos produciendo con otros con
otro equipo técnico también entonces a
ver y además esto es muy muy grande yo
siempre digo para la gente que no lo
conoce tal vez sirva el dato yo que
tengo la costumbre de adonde viajó
visitó los medios de comunicación
locales
conozco bueno entre otras corrientes los
grandes grandes grandes conozco a la bbc
conozco la cnn etcétera y salvo la sede
central de la bbc en bus house creo que
no hay nada más grande que el radio
canadá internacional en cuanto a
dimensiones de las instituciones me
refiero no es cierto yo visité una de
las oficinas ya cnn en el centro de
manhattan en nueva york hace ya unos
cuantos años y ni siquiera ese edificio
es tan grande como este esto es un
complejo que realmente deja sin aliento
yo hace 15 años que vengo aquí
de hecho no conozco ni siquiera la mitad
de los pisos de la torre central no es
grandísima y lo que es cierto es que
está chiquita comparada con la de
toronto sí porque la sede de la canadian
broadcasting corporation que es la misma
cosa que radio canadá pero en inglés en
toronto es más grande que es la k
entonces este es radio canadá en francés
principalmente el equipo de radio canadá
internacional es mucho más reducido como
ustedes todos lo saben pero en toronto
hay mucha gente trabajando y es enorme
la sede más grande son la de toronto la
de montreal es bastante más pequeña la
nota o expuesto a las demás son mucho
más pequeñas
de costa a costa si vice radio canasta
de costa a costa está en todo bien todo
está nada pero salvo las instalaciones
de toronto como vos decías palomas la de
montreal y en tercer lugar la nota o las
demás son mucho más pequeñas y son más
reducidas de todas maneras con estas
tres más grandes alcances obras
el tema de canadá
se deberían agregarle un marea y porque
también está el océano ártico también
verdad bueno teníamos entonces ahí las
imágenes de la sede que pronto vamos a
las que pronto nos vamos a desplazar
supongo yo espero en todo caso y ya les
podríamos mostrar también cómo es por
adentro cuando estemos ya moviéndonos
por ahí trabajando y también no trabajar
tratando de bueno en los últimos diez
minutos y medio que nos quedan vamos a
entonces presentarles entre otras cosas
a nuestros oyentes las sugerencias de
los materiales que hemos ido trabajando
a lo largo de esta semana invitó
entonces a paloma en mira al lugar mero
que nos presente cuáles de todos los
climas que va a producirse esta semana
el que les sugerí dice en primer término
al público porque es verdad que
producimos bastante contenido durante
toda la semana pero hay uno que me llama
particularmente la atención es una
entrevista que hice con rubén francisco
martínez lópez
él es un estudiante de doctorado en
toxicología ambiente
quien vino a la universidad de ottawa a
formar parte de parte de un equipo que
se puso a investigar unos contaminantes
nuevos contaminantes son dos
contaminantes artificiales identificados
ambos utilizados en la industria china
particularmente y que tienen efectos
similares a otros contaminantes que ya
han sido prohibidos y que tienen efectos
en la salud humana directamente y en
cosas que a lo mejor uno no podría
imaginarse que afectan en la obesidad en
los niveles de autoridad en los niveles
de diabetes e incluso en la anorexia en
la dificultad digamos a comer que tienen
muchas personas en los tres temas graves
tres temas graves de salud pública
entonces estos contaminantes que ellos
identificaron lo que es particular es
que están reemplazando que son
utilizados en china y en otras regiones
del mundo son utilizados para reemplazar
otros que ya habían sido prohibidos
entonces cuando se prohibió con la con
la convención de estocolmo algunas
sustancias en particular
estos contaminantes fueron digamos no
contaminantes son sus sustancias que
fueron creadas para reemplazar las que
habían sido prohibidas y finalmente
resultaron ser contaminantes serán
persistentes y tan dañinos como los
primeros que fueron prohibidos entonces
estos investigadores de la universidad
de ottawa se dieron cuenta que hay que
hacer algo están intentando que otras
organizaciones en todo el mundo otros
grupos de investigación en todo el mundo
hagan lo mismo que ellos que comprueben
por qué tienen que haber varias pruebas
para que algo así sea prohibido a nivel
internacional en una convención como la
de estocolmo entonces están trabajando
duro para crear lazos entre los entre
los diferentes investigadores del mundo
para comprobar que esto está afectando
directamente a la salud humana a los
niveles de obesidad de diabetes y de
anorexia en los difer en las diferentes
regiones del mundo donde estos
compuestos las sustancias están
presentes y no recordar así lo dijiste
pero está el dato allí en donde se puede
encontrar con más frecuencia este tipo
de grupos en todos lados louis porque
sabes que están utilizados estos
compuestos los utilizan en la
el cromado de los autos deformado de
metales y también en otra industria que
también es muy escapó por acá pero bueno
en por lo menos en el cromado de metales
lo cual por supuesto todos los autos
tienen vivo tus autos y motocicletas
tienen cromado utiliza el cromado
entonces realmente podrían todas las
piezas hechas en china que son cromadas
podrían potencialmente tener este tipo
de materiales incluidos y podrían estar
dañando la salud de las sociedades bueno
perfecto es ese entonces el tema que nos
sugieren paloma martínez y que les
sugiero a ustedes paloma martínez para
consultar en primer término si durante
esta semana después de trabajado duro
para vos también tienes una sugerencia
que hacerle al público sí sí sí claro
mira en primero quiero recordarles que
del 21 de octubre hubo elecciones
federales aquí en canadá y fue el primer
ministro yo esté trudeau quien resultó
reelecto reelecto minoritario estado y
la primera vez fue mayoritario la
segunda vez fue minoritario bueno la
elección de ellos dentro de creó una
crisis entre comillas en el partido
conservador canadiense que es el partido
de oficial de la oposición oficial que
llevó a la renuncia del entonces jefe
del partido conservador andrew siga
vamos a hacer una pequeñita declaración
que es que en caudal de votos el partido
conservador zac con más papeletas que el
partido liberal pero por el sistema
electoral vigente en canadá no obtuvo la
cantidad de bancas suficientes en el
parlamento para sobrepasar a los
liberales es por eso que el partido
liberal es gobierno en minoría y en todo
caso la segunda minoría
en los conservadores ya sucedió lo que
sucedió con donald trump y la distinta
que ella tuvo más votos pero fue trump
el que ganó bueno regresando lo nuestro
se renunció
andrús y er y se lanzó una campaña para
para escoger el nuevo líder del partido
conservador y bueno entonces en esa está
canadá en este momento y ayer justamente
anteayer el ex primer ministro
conservador stephen harper que después
de la derrota que tuvo en el 2015 contra
el mismo just incluso cuando los
liberales fueron mayoritarios él pues se
retiró un poco de la de las pantallas y
siguiendo un poco lo que la tradición
aquí también exacto si y bueno entonces
fue nombrado director del fondo de
recaudación de fondos del partido no
desde el partido conservador y el
anteayer renunció entonces a ese
a su cargo de director lo que
desencadenó toda una serie de hipótesis
y de preguntas de por qué había
renunciado una de ellas era que
renunciaba porque no quiere que uno de
los potenciales candidatos que es el ex
primer ministro de québec jean charest
se presente porque hay una disputa y
entre ellos y finalmente pues resulta
que hay varios análisis que se han hecho
sobre eso y que van a ver en ese
reportaje entre otros pues que una
cronista analista política de esta casa
entre otros que trabaja para esta casa
santa le vert ella dice que finalmente
pues no fue tanto como para bloquearle
el paso
ranieri sino para permitirle al ex
primer ministro de poder ya sin tener
esa obligación con el partido de poderse
expresar algo esencialmente posicionarse
en esta campaña entonces para el resto
de la historia y como es un poco larga
pues se la dejo en el nuestro sitio
internet para que les contiene la de que
la gente se entere cómo viene esto de
esta marca o dulce rebaja sutil
bueno yo le sugiero en todo caso
humildemente al público un material de
los que produce esta semana que tiene
que ver con la existencia del hambre
infantil en canadá ya lo hemos referido
en alguna ocasión en primer término
hablar de hambre en canadá que son los
países más desarrollados del mundo que
entre que integra el grupo selecto de
los países más desarrollados del mundo
mucha gente no lo crea que son muy
poquitos hay hambre de todas maneras en
canadá pobreza y pobreza también en
canadá puede ser que tiene otros
estándares a los que se pueden registrar
en otras partes del mundo eso es cierto
también pero la verdad es que lo hay hay
un informe reciente que produjo una
entidad que se llama campaña 2000 sigue
reducimos al español su nombre este
nombre viene precisamente de un proyecto
que había seguido sancionado en algún
momento en el parlamento canadiense y
que se había fijado por ese entonces
creo que fue en los años 80 o 90 no me
acuerdo exactamente ahora pero que había
fijado el tope del año 2000
para terminar con el hambre infantil en
canadá estamos en el 2020 diremos sobre
pasados 20 años es ese plazo y lo cierto
es que el hambre no se ha terminado dice
este organismo y dicen algunos sondeos
que se han hecho recientemente es que
verdad que ha habido unas leves mejorías
en los últimos años pero lo cierto es
que hay aún hoy más de un millón 350 mil
niños o menores de edad en todo caso que
padecen necesidades nutritivas y que
padecen dicho de manera simple hambre en
canadá es decir no pueden alimentarse de
manera correcta y suficiente es muy cara
la comida en canadá les multan esa
regreso es muy cara y bueno hay una gran
cantidad de datos en este material para
darles uno solo que ustedes tengan una
una magnitud más aproximada de lo que
estamos hablando el 18,6 por ciento de
las personas menores de 18 años de edad
experimentan situaciones de pobreza
si estamos hablando de prácticamente el
20 por ciento de los jóvenes por debajo
de los 18 años son pobres o tienen
problemas para alimentarse en canadá
tienen todo el material disponible ya en
el sitio de internet
hay muchas estadísticas me gusta a mí
poner estadísticas porque creo que
hablan que son claras que reflejan la
situación porque juntos ya tenemos
mensajes de andrés ya tran que nos
escribe desde la menos exótica dice y
fría ciudad de la asunción aquí en
quebec y con más comentarios
relacionados con los reportajes los
contaminantes en el tema de pablo
saludos especiales así que muchísimas
gracias a todos por seguirnos liliana
paredes hay los mismos comentarios que
el que vimos hace rato pero hay todavía
más vayan a escribirnos estamos aquí
como iniciamos cada viernes y es un
gusto para nosotros reencontrarnos
supongo que será un gusto para ustedes
también reencontrarnos a nosotros
y una vez más dentro de una semana
[Música]